how have you suffered publicly as a
result of the dep waldman statements
i am
harassed
humiliated
threatened
every single day
even just walking into this courtroom
sitting here
in front of the world
having the worst parts of my life
things i've lived through used to
humiliate me
people want to kill me
and they tell me so
every day
people want to put my baby in the
microwave
and they tell me that
johnny
threatened
promised
promised me
that if i ever left him he'd make me
think of him
every single day
that i lived
objection your honor non-responsive
all right i'll sustain the objection as
to that if you want to ask the question
amber
how did mr depp's
statements and threats to you that you
were discussing
how do those continue to manifest
themselves today
in the harassment and the humiliation
the campaign against me that's echoed
every single day
on social media and now
in front of cameras in this room
every single day i have to relive the
trauma
my hands shake i wake up screaming i
have to live with the trauma and the
damage done to me
my friends have to live with a set of
unspoken rules about how to not scare me
about how to not touch me
not to surprise me
my intimate partners
have rules about how they can deal with
me how they can touch me
i have rules for doctors medical
professionals i see gynecologists i see
i live my life
with these sets of rules that i have to
follow my friends have to follow for me
not to have a panic attack or a
triggering event
where i relive the trauma i'm not
sitting in this courtroom snickering i'm
not sitting in this courtroom laughing
smiling making snide jokes i'm not
this is horrible
this is painful
and this is humiliating for any human
being
to go through
and perhaps it's easy to forget that but
i'm a human being
and even though johnny promised that i
deserved this and promised you do this i
don't deserve this
want to move on
i receive
hundreds
of death threats
regularly if not daily
thousands since this trial has started
people
mocking mocking
my testimony about being assaulted
making fun of my objection relevance
non-responsiveness
you can continue
it's been
agonizing
agonizing
painful
and most humiliating
thing i've ever had to go through
oh no one ever has to go through
something like this
oh
i just want johnny to leave me alone i
just want him to leave me alone
i've said that
for years now miss her you just
testified that this case has been very
hard for you so let's talk about that
and why
all right
your lies have been exposed to the world
multiple times right
i've been lied about anything i've been
here to say
you sat here and told this jury that the
events in hicksville started with mr
depp getting really upset about a woman
leaning on you is that correct
yes that's effectively what happened
yeah you testified that once you brought
mr depp back to your trailer he trashed
it correct
that is correct
and the manager of the hicksville
trailer park was furious that johnny had
wrecked the whole thing do you remember
that testimony that's correct well we
heard from that manager of the
hicksville trailer park morgan knight on
monday didn't we
i'm not quite sure who that guy was or
if he had any involvement in this i know
a lot of people have come out of the
woodwork to be
involved
so you're accusing mr knight of
testifying
and committing perjury i'm not accusing
anyone i just don't recognize that man
you heard mr knight testify that it was
actually you who was upset with mr depp
spending time away from him isn't that
correct
how would he know he wasn't there you
heard mr knight testify that it was
actually you who was yelling at mr dub
again
i've heard a lot of people say a lot of
things to be involved in the johnny depp
show but
he wasn't there
he doesn't know and he certainly doesn't
know what happened behind closed doors
like most people so you're calling mr
knight a liar
i am saying he wasn't there and what he
testified to doesn't match what i know
happened
but i don't fault him he wasn't there so
how would he know
he testified he was there misheard did
you hear that that's his testimony yes
so you're calling him a liar
i'm just saying he wasn't there
at the beginning of your
cross-examination last week i showed you
an audio where you told mr deb tell the
jury
tell the judge tell the world that he is
a victim of domestic abuse do you
remember that that's correct you
testified you found it hard to believe
that mr depp would tell the world that
he's a victim of domestic abuse
didn't you
i said i find it hard to believe that he
would do that knowing that he himself
had beat me up for five years but he has
told the world that he's your victim of
domestic abuse hasn't he
well he started to say that only
recently he didn't make that claim up
until very recently so when we signed
our divorce agreement and we signed a
statement saying that neither party had
ever said false claims for financial
gain
it was relevant and important to me
because i was the only one making the
accusations i was the only one making
those claims he wasn't doing that at the
time and he signed his name to it
you didn't expect as many people to show
up and testify on his behalf
that did did you
incorrect
when you told this jury under oath that
you punched mr depp because you thought
of mr depp pushing kate moss down the
stairs you didn't expect miss moss to
agree to testify that that never
happened did you incorrect i know how
many people will come out of the
woodwork to be in support of johnny so
you think this mom needs to come out of
the woodwork to testify for mr depp
everybody who was around in the 90s and
the early aughts knew that rumor i had
heard that rumor from multiple people of
course that's what flashed through my
head when my violent husband not only
swung for me but all of a sudden swung
for my sister of course i thought of
that i did not expect her to show up or
not expect her to show up it didn't
matter it doesn't change what i believed
at the time when we were on the stairs
and i thought he was going to kill my
sister by pushing her down the stairs
you told this jury under oath and mr
depp was aggressive and trashed a
trailer in hicksville you didn't expect
the manager of the hicksville property
morgan knight to come forward and
testify that that wasn't true did you
incorrect i've already been through
trials with this man i know how many
people will come out in support of him
when you told this jury under oath that
you had no idea that the paparazzi would
be at the courthouse on may 27 2016 you
didn't expect a tmz employee to show up
to testify that tmz had been alerted
that you would be at the courthouse and
knew exactly which side of your face to
take a picture of did you
i know how many people will come out and
say whatever for him that's his power
that's why i wrote the op-ed is i was
speaking to that phenomenon how many
people will come out in support of him
and will fall to his power he is a very
powerful man and people love currying
favor we're powerful men and i know that
firsthand jail time for committing
perjury
excuse me
i didn't i didn't hear your questions
any question
ms vasquez if you do
please just repeat the question i didn't
hear you curry favor and commit perjury
in this courtroom
i have a powerful man i have seen people
do this time and time again
that's why i wrote the op-ed